millie bobby brown is an intense actor
some may say she is even going a bit
method so she gets herself into some
painful situations for the sake of her
art ready to find out what made her
vomit or how about how she navigated her
broken knee
number one this is why actors sign
contracts that they won't engage in
dangerous activities i have
split my kneecap while this incident
didn't happen on the set of stranger
things it was still healing while millie
was filming and so she leaned on her
stunt double for support her double not
only had to do all of her stunts but
even some of the simpler tasks too like
riding a bicycle hey they should have
put her in the basket like they did with
e.t that was the inspiration for eleven
number two how did women used to wear
these all the time for anola homes
millie was wearing such a tight-laced
corset that it was painful for her and
she struggled with her fight scenes
fighting in a dress is never easy but
luckily the director had the forethought
to use the dress as a tool rather than
ignore its existence do not be deterred
from wearing a corset though you
actually have to do waste training to
get your waist used to the shape in
stages and if you think it's such an
outdated thing ear stretching is not all
that different of a concept but actors
generally don't have the time for waste
training and suffer through squishing
their organs instead number three this
scenario seems like it was totally
avoidable with a little forethought due
to the cold temperature that they were
filming stranger things in millie
struggled to do a scene in which she was
submerged in freezing cold water they
did try to heat the pool but it was just
too shallow to retain any heat did
anybody think about
maybe heating the air as well number
four while vechna may not be as spooky
as the smokey dude from the previous
season he was physically there on set
jamie campbell bauer messed millie up
filming stranger things his character
was so far from himself when he
transformed from henry into vechna that
it freaked millie out and made her cry
bower said she was terrified like
literally terrified and when she saw
vacna she burst into tears and she said
that's not my friend i don't know who
this person is anymore where's he gone
was this acting jaime was the one having
a hard time getting through the scene
maybe millie just messed him up number 5
the bullies were a tad cliche but that
doesn't take away from millie's
experience filming the bullying for
season four of stranger things also
mentally messed with millie say that
five times fast the scene at the rinko
mania where everyone is pointing made
her incredibly distressed and sad it
also hit noah schnapp really hard having
to just witness it and not be able to
help at all
number 6. did the duffers forget they
were working with children millie was
exhausted from overworking herself on
set long days not enough sleep and
mentally straining scenes led her to
collapsing into finn wolfhard's arms
weeping from sheer exhaustion the scene
actually made it into the show and you
can see in the shot finn break character
and look up for help luckily the panic
is as real as his character could have
mustered up we hope after that they let
the poor girl take a nap
number seven just the name of this stunt
sounds dangerous the corkscrew move
millie pulled in enola homes can get you
all twisted up if done wrong talk about
another knee injury waiting to happen
you can see in the movie how she does
get twisted up too number eight millie
is not a huge fan of any stunts done on
wires but one stranger thing stunt left
her so dizzy she vomited we had to do
like a rotation one once where i was
just constantly going upside down which
kind of sucked after spinning around and
around in circles take after take of
course she vomited number nine millie's
made of bricks just like the wall she's
being thrown against we swear for anola
millie was thrown up against a wall 15
times in a row she totally just brushes
it off but man does that look painful
number 10 the key to great acting is to
show up with your lines half memorized
lily said filming anola being drowned
was very safe she was in total control
but because of the quick loss of oxygen
she could only stick her head under for
about 15 seconds she went into the scene
with her lines memorized five minutes
before so she could give a genuine
performance of stumbling over her words
number eleven can somebody get her a t
or something millie lost her voice like
four times during the filming of
stranger things because she had to
scream so much then she lost her voice
again when she returned to the booth for
adr while this is all fine and well when
you're young you want to be careful
doing this stuff long term or there
could be serious repercussions number
12. the mind may know acting isn't real
but the body doesn't the reunion between
11 and cali was intense for millie not
only did it just make her weepy but she
also took her work home with her and it
was just so overwhelming
oh millie go easy on yourself the art
will still be good even if you aren't
pushing yourself to your breaking point
method acting for such a young star
sounds dangerous do you think millie's
method is safe oppose our opinions in
the comments we promise we won't bite
back and thanks for hanging out with us
here at the things